-Everybody, welcome back.
Let's just jump right into it.
So there's always
one thing every week
that we get
the most feedback on.
This is actually from
yesterday's Closer Look.
We had a satellite
explode in space,
and the two things
we heard the most is,
one, in space,
you would not hear an explosion,
and in space,
when a satellite exploded,
the debris wouldn't
fall straight down
because of the lack of gravity.
And it rankles me pretty bad,
because when we hire people
into our Graphics department,
the two questions
we ask them is
one, do you know how
to do graphics?
And two,
do you understand
how space works?
And somebody pointed it out,
wrote, "Jackals: 1.
Graphic: 0,"
and you just couldn't
be more wrong.
They don't feel like this
is a defeat at all.
This is how they flirt.
They make mistakes on purpose,
the way someone leaves,
like, a perfumed handkerchief
at a Victorian ball.
And then I'm stuck
going down there saying,
"Guys, do you not know
the properties of space?"
And they're like,
"Oh, no, did we get it wrong?
Did someone find our mistake?"
It's not just that.
You know, we talked about it
last week.
We talked about
this problematic pigeon graphic
where the nostrils were exposed,
and as so many of you said,
that's, again,
the least of the problem.
What wall has bricks
going that way?
Who...? When have you...?
And again, so that I'm
down there being like,
"Guys, what is this?"
And they're like, "Oh,
is that not how bricks work?
Did somebody find it
and leave a comment?"
Pete Rose did not ever
bet against the Reds.
We had in the Closer Look
that Pete Rose was on the phone
with his bookies,
and people wanted
to make it very clear
that he maybe did a lot of
things, he bet on baseball.
He never
bet against his own team.
Alright,
early days of corrections,
we talked about
the correct way
to pronounce
the Irish political position
the Taoiseach,
which is like
the Irish prime minister.
We spent a lot of time
talking about it.
We went back and forth.
Guys, this is a true thing
that happened.
Last week, the actual taoiseach
was in our studio
and nobody got me.
Nobody thought, "Oh, that might
be interesting to Seth,
who's talked about it
at length."
I mean, what in the world?
That's like somebody saying,
"Yeah, no.
Werner Herzog
and Christoph Waltz
were in the studio,
but we didn't want to get you.
We thought you were busy."
They sound very different.
So then I was, you know,
obviously, I'm pretty angry
and I'm like,
"Did nobody think to get me?"
And they said, "Well, we told
Graphics to tell you."
And I'm like --
I'm like, "Graphics, did you?"
And they're like, "We slipped
a note under the door."
And I'm like, "My door?"
They're like, "No, just a door."
People have been
lamenting the fact
that for as much as
he's talked about,
Shoemaker is never on camera,
and that it would, I don't know,
enrich this experience
if they knew
what Shoemaker looked like.
He's not,
but here's the thing --
he doesn't want to be on camera.
He's not getting on camera,
so I will just --
just to paint
a picture for you.
He is a fairly nondescript,
middle-aged man
with the most
lustrous head of hair.
Like, just long,
down to the shoulders,
just like,
a beautiful, blond mane.
And he's always like, that's...
I've done impressions of of him
that I think
are fairly accurate,
but that's the one thing
I do always leave out.
Because he's always like,
"Who's asking?"
And he's always talking about,
like, how he wants a new brush.
He's like, "I was walking down
Fifth Avenue.
I saw this gorgeous
antique brush,
but I can't afford it.
One day.
One day, I'm going to get
that beautiful antique brush."
Some people said
my Randy Newman,
which I think
we've established is good,
sounds like Bill Cosby.
I don't know.
[ As Randy Newman ]
"Roll down the window.
Put down the top.
Turn up the Beach Boys, baby.
Hand me that
Jell-o Pudding Pop."
Called Andy Samberg last week,
and I asked him to
sing Fine Young Cannibals
for us.
I said, "Sing us the song,
'She Drives You Crazy.'"
People said the song is
"She Drives Me Crazy."
That's what it is
when he's singing it,
but if you're asking
another person to sing it,
you switch the pronouns.
So if I want him to sing,
"She Drives Me Crazy,"
I have to say, sing
"She Drives You Crazy."
That's just common sense.
Also, people did not believe
it was a real call.
It was a real call.
I did not think
he was going to answer.
I think we were
incredibly lucky last week.
We'll try it again here.
[ Cellphone rings ]
See, that's real time,
right there.
[ Cellphone ringing ]
I guess we're not gonna
get him this week.
[ Cellphone ringing ]
That's how it works.
Corrections.
It's like watching sports.
It's the thrill of the live.
I referred to the "Fast Five"
movie franchise.
"Fast Five" was the name
of one of the movies.
I don't know which one.
I also said that if I were in
a "Fast and the Furious" movie,
I would be a guy
holding out a coffee
and then a car would
come by and be like, "Whoa!"
And Vin Diesel would be like,
"Oh, a [bleep] latte"
and throw it out the window.
And people were like,
"Hey, based on the way
you did that,
he would either have to be
in the wrong lane
or driving backwards."
Does that not happen
in those movies?
Because I'm pretty sure
in the trailers,
Vin Diesel often says,
"Hold on,"
and then just like, vroom.
I did say that I also --
a good role for me in the movie
would be carrying across,
like, a plate of glass.
And someone said,
"I love that Seth Meyers thinks
the 'Fast and the Furious'
movies are like
'70s car chase comedies."
It's a very fair observation.
So I think if I were in
a "Fast and the Furious" movie,
I bet a good role for me
would be someone
who would say something like,
"I get it.
You're all a bunch of cowboys."
I referred to "Lillehammer,"
the Little Steven
show on Netflix,
and people said, "Yes, that is
the name of the Norwegian city,
but the show is called
"Lilyhammer,"
because that was how
his character said it, so...
Also, not a correction,
but I feel like
we have underappreciated
what a good actor
Little Steven is.
So that would be like,
a correction to how
well-received...
I feel like we've underestimated
exactly how great he was.
I referred to Pavarotti as
a B-list celebrity.
Some opera enthusiasts
took issue with that, but
I should have said --
We should've made this clear,
when I say B-list
about an Italian,
it means "bellissimo."
You guys, if you haven't
noticed, I'm wearing
sweater sleeves.
So...
[ Exhales deeply ]
Last week, my worst mistake
was I referred to...
something that Patty Lyons
sewed for me as a sweater.
You guys all pointed out
that it was a sweater vest.
And I --
It was a bad mistake,
and I spent a lot of the week
pretty upset about it.
Like, mad at myself
for missing something so easy,
because it was clearly a sweater
vest, and I called it a sweater,
And sometimes I am a little
bit harder on myself than
I maybe present out here.
And...
I think Shoemaker noticed,
because today he came in
with a gift box.
And also, all his hair
had been cut off.
And I said, "Oh my God, what?
Where's your hair?
Where's your beautiful hair?"
And he said,
"You know, this wig maker's
always been asking me for it.
Said it was the most
beautiful hair she'd ever seen.
I sold it to her."
And I was like,
"Sold it to her? Why?"
And he said, "I wanted
to get you something,
because I see
how down you've been."
And he hands me this box,
and I open it up,
and it's these sleeves.
And he says,
"Now it's a sweater.
You put that on the vest,
you walk out there,
you show those jackals
who you are."
And I said, "I can't.
I can't."
And when he asked why not,
I said, "I..."
[ Bag rustling ]
"I sold the sweater
to get you this."
I think --
I think that's everything.
See me next week.